it still remains a mystery
how this baby minky whale became stuck
in the thames
in south west london but by in richmond
believed they were among the first to
see it trapped in the lock
when they raised the alarm at 6 00 pm on
sunday evening
we called in the port of london
authority
eventually we got up here we saw him
being stuck again we called
the port of london authority again the
guys from the lock
came by to water him down nobody
no one was allowed to touch him or
anything like that so we're
not able to do anything or help in any
way and now we're back just to see
just to check what we were hoping yeah
not to see anyone at all
as the evening drew in it became a
combined effort to float the whale
and maneuver it to safety a team of
water rescue firefighters
and marine specialists tried to shift
the mammal onto inflatable pontoon
crafts
but there were several failed rescue
attempts
throughout the mission the wales welfare
was a prime concern for the teams
trying to help it to safety she's not
he or she we're not sure isn't nicely
rounded like a healthy whale would be
so possibly nutritionally compromised
there's also
um some damage to the pectoral fins from
stranding and also
the skin is showing signs that perhaps
it was stranded earlier in the day
somewhere as well
in fairly poor condition but now it's
quite comfortable
the breathing rate's nice and low
[Music]
in the early hours of monday morning
crowds cheered
as the whale was eventually moved by
authorities
the whale was taken from a non-tidal
lock area to a stable area
where they would then take further
assessments on what is best for the
whale
and moving forward in weaver to take it
out to sea or to work on it further
and the best interest for the whale
itself vets will now continue to assess
the creature's condition
to determine whether it's healthy enough
to be released
anisha sethi sky news